there is new controversy today over how
an L.A County Sheriff's deputy reacted
when a woman started filming an arrest
on her phone body cam footage shows what
happened on June 24th in Lancaster
California as officers responded to an
allegation of shoplifting warning parts
of this footage is disturbing Atlanta
has the details
we're just gonna pat you down but body
cam worn by a Los Angeles County
Sheriff's deputy shows him and other
deputies arriving outside of grocery
store in Lancaster and questioning a man
and woman accused of shoplifting
deputies then placed the man in
handcuffs one of the deputies then turns
to the woman who was recording the
incident on her cell phone another
witness is also capturing the incident
in her car now you can't touch it the
video then appears to show the deputies
slamming the woman to the ground
stop
stop and get it punched in the face the
deputy's knee can be seen on the woman's
neck
the deputy then douses the woman with
what appears to be pepper spray
and then places her in handcuffs after a
brief struggle the deputies then placed
the couple in separate police cruisers
in a statement to CBS News the Los
Angeles County Sheriff's Department says
it has opened an investigation and while
not commenting directly on the incident
said it expects Department Personnel to
treat all members of the public with
dignity and respect both deputies in the
incident who have not been identified
have been reassigned from field Duty
pending the outcome of the investigation
for CBS mornings I'm Elaine quijano
as for the man and woman in that video
the L.A County Sheriff's Department says
they were cited and eventually released
no reason was given for the citation and
you read that video was very difficult
to watch